اصعب امتحان للالتحاق بالجامعات في العالم
وين يوجد في الصين
يسمى
وبدا اليوم الاربعاء ويستمر ليومين الى
اربعه ايام اختيار المواد تحديدا توجه هذا
العام يا راويه نحو 13 مليون طالب وطالبه
لتاديه الامتحان الذي بدات تطبيقه عام
1977 ويعد الاصعب ايضا في العالم كون
القبول يعتمد بشكل اساسي على نتائج
الامتحان بدلا من التقدير العام للاداب
الاكاديمي او الاداء الاكاديمي للطالب
بحيث ان هذا الظلم نوعا ما انه كل يعني
نتيجتك كلها تعتمد على نتيجتك في الامتحان
الفلاني طيب اذا كان يوميتها انت رايح
تعبان صار اي ظرف معك ممكن ياثر على
نتيجتك وعلى مستقبلك يعني لازم يكون
التقييم شوي اشمل واعم من ذلك من 77 مفصل
هال امتحان
امتحانات بشكل عام وخصوصا انه هلا كثير من
الاطفال عم بيعملوا امتحانات لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات